three days of digging
and this olive ridley turtle
is free
but not safe
until she gets to the sea
where early life evolved
and where nearly 80 percent of animals
still
live of all the hatchlings born this
year on the costa rican coast
only 10
will make it
now she's in her element
but her journey has just begun
[Music]
in 10 years time she will return to
these shores to lay eggs of her own
if she survives
[Music]
the ocean is a fluid and unpredictable
world
and all those that live here
are at its mercy
[Music]
our planet's oceans cover 70 of its
surface
[Music]
and provide an incredible 99
of his habitable space
this may be an alien world to us
but it's home to an extraordinary range
of animals
from the biggest
to the strangest creatures in our world
even for the most marine adapted
life isn't easy
survival at sea
is a completely different game
to survival on land
especially
when the rules keep changing
[Music]
where the atlantic and indian oceans
meet
new conflicts between old foes are
brewing
rising sea temperatures are pushing fish
eastward to cooler waters
those that feed on them have followed
[Music]
fur seals
their new home is treacherous
and it's not just the waves
[Music]
it's what lies beneath
not the best place
to learn to swim
[Music]
but the perfect hunting ground for a
great white shark
this pump has strayed too close to the
edge
now it's out of its depth
a puck can outmaneuver a shark
but only for so long
half of all such encounters end badly
for seals
the adults must deal with this
persistent menace
but how
it takes one brave seal to lead the way
so
others join
soon they are a mob
harassing the intruder
it's a risky strategy
sharks can turn on a dime
together they've overcome a giant
the pups are safe
at least for now
shallow continental seas are the most
productive waters in our oceans
they're also some of the most
competitive
[Music]
during winter
these freezing fields are the stage for
one of the biggest wildlife spectacles
on the planet
this orca pod comes here every
year they're led by a matriarch
she could be 70 years old
for a pot that specializes in hunting
fish
this is an unmissable event
herring
billions of them
more fish here than people on the planet
but the bigger the show
the harder it is to single out a target
the orca need to come at the problem
from another angle
coordinating their attack
they divide and conquer
herders work to split the shoal
then in come the big hitters
their tails creating a shock wave
stunning up to 30 fish with each blow
they must work quickly
they're not the only hunters here
humpbacks
six times the weight of an orca
they can devour more than 200 pounds of
herring in one gulp
the orca simply can't compete
but they can switch tactic
as long as they're prepared to face down
the most dangerous predator in the ocean
in the ocean where there is food
there's usually a fight
[Music]
off the fields of norway
these orca are about to take on the most
aggressive ocean hunters of all
us
fishing boats like this can scoop up 800
tons of herring a day
out fishing orca and humpbacks combined
desperation has forced these orca
to turn this new obstacle into
opportunity
off the fish that slipped through their
competitors
[Music]
recently imposed quotas ensure there are
enough herring for humans and whales
but the global picture isn't so bright
we are consuming more fish than ever
before
reducing many stocks to little more than
scales
unbalanced oceans are open to invasion
by strange life forms
[Music]
[Music]
they start life as pinhead sized polyps
but what they lack in size
they make up for in numbers
[Music]
[Music]
gorging on tiny plankton
they grow
mutate
and multiply
into an army of clones
now each polyp becomes a production line
with one purpose
creating new jellyfish
bodies that are 95 water can easily grow
and grow
until they are monsters
no bones
no blood or even brains
but perfectly suited to today's
transforming seas
resistant to increasing temperature
decreasing oxygen
changing salinity
rising acidity
even plastic pollution
when a jellyfish swarm takes over
some ecosystems never fully recover
our impact also extends to the biggest
marine habitat of all
the open ocean
[Music]
it covers more than half the globe
the food here is increasingly scarce
[Music]
yet one animal perseveres
despite needing one and a half million
calories every day
the blue whale
the largest animal ever to have lived
she's as long as an 18-wheeler
with a heart as big as a car
and a ton that weighs as much as an
elephant
[Music]
just this year she swum far enough
to have circumnavigated the globe
[Music]
all in search
of this
krill
one of the most important species in the
marine food chain
with each monumental gulp
she takes in enough water and krill
to fill the school bus
her tongue forces the water back out
through the bristly plates on her jaw
trapping up to two million krill
blue whales were hunted to the brink of
extinction although they're still in
danger
since a ban on whaling in the 1960s
their numbers have increased worldwide
and here
off the coast of california
they've almost completely recovered
the vast open ocean
can be a lonely place
this green turtle has spent 30 years out
here on her own
somehow she's found enough food to
survive and grow
[Music]
now she's ready to return home
but it will be a dangerous journey
[Music]
it's the breeding season
and hundreds of turtles are gathering to
try and win a partner
males mate about four times as often as
females
so she attracts a lot of interest
this male is quick to latch on
[Applause]
but the others won't give up without a
fight
off the coast of malaysia
it's green turtle breeding season
this female has found a mate
but other males are intent on splitting
the pair
targeting the male soft flesh
they tried to force him to let go
but the female has the most to lose
the fiercer the pursuit
the more oxygen she burns
the stressed turtle can drown in minutes
she's desperate to reach a surface and
breathe
but one challenger just won't give up
the female is running on empty
finally the intruder backs off just long
enough
she's safe
but in just a few weeks she will face
the final hurdle in her epic struggle to
continue her line
where the tropical sun meets the shallow
seas
you find the busiest ocean habitat of
all
coral reefs
[Music]
they account for less than a thousandth
of the sea floor
but a home to a quarter of all marine
species
in this crowded and dangerous place
finding shelter is essential
some hide in the coral maze
others seek sanctuary in the shop
but neither tactic guarantees safety
lionfish are one of the most efficient
killers on the reef
yet there is a far greater threat facing
all those who live here
our seas have been steadily warming for
the past 75 years
now it's happening faster than ever
before
it's having a profound impact on life
throughout our oceans
coral reefs are particularly vulnerable
just a three degree temperature rise
it's too much for coral
it forces them to expel the algae that
feed them
and give them their colour
this bleaching is a first step towards
an almost irreversible demise
unless temperatures drop
the reef becomes a wasteland
in three decades we've lost over a
quarter of the world's corals
home to around 4 000 species of fish
if warming continues
we could lose the rest
even those that live far below aren't
safe from rising ocean temperatures
[Music]
opalescent squid
[Music]
in the past few years warming seas
disrupted their mating habits
and the numbers have fallen dramatically
but this year an influx of cold water
has revived their breeding ritual
a trip to the shallows to mate
by moonlight
males grab the females and fertilize
their eggs
which are then deposited on the sea
floor
it's a brief and brutal affair
within days of mating they will all die
but their legacy lives on
each capsule contains up to 300 new
lives
one successful breeding season can go a
long way towards reversing their recent
bad fortunes
those still alive retreat back to a
place beyond the reach of the sun
[Music]
where crushing pressures have morphed
bodies
into the stuff of nightmares
[Applause]
[Music]
to reach one of the most hostile
environments on earth
you must descend thousands of feet
beyond the sun's reach
down into the ocean's depths
the pressure here would crush you like a
soda can
there is life
just not as we know it
75 of animals make their own
light eyes are supersized
to catch what tiny luminescence there is
[Music]
and soft bodies dominate
[Music]
in this vast abyssal wilderness
one of the toughest trials
is finding a mate
anglerfish have a grizzly solution
this giant female's tiny hangar on is a
male anglerfish
many males never find a mate
those that do
never let go
his mouth fuses with her very tissue
his only nourishment her blood
bonded
for life
this alien environment is full of
surprises
it even snows down here
of organic matter fall for weeks towards
the sea floor
along the way they fuel an ecosystem of
microscopic animals
and graceful giants
the stygio medusa jellyfish
its ribbon-like arms extend up to 30
feet to absorb tiny plaque tonic
creatures
also we believe
even today the lives of these deep sea
monsters remain shrouded in mystery
but the biggest surprise of all
this marine underworld is one of the
most stable habitats on the planet
out of touch with what's happening far
above
the sun has fueled a monster
it heats surface waters until they
evaporate
and build into oceanic storms that
render humans powerless
and when conditions are just right they
grow into one of the most formidable
forces on the planet
hurricanes
they form over tropical seas then their
devastation spreads
they release so much energy that just
one could power our entire planet for a
week
and as global temperatures rise
hurricanes are growing stronger
this is the calm before the storm
most people were already taking shelter
but just offshore
others are on the move
[Music]
mullet
in their millions
few have heard of it but this is one of
the largest gatherings of any animal in
the united states
[Music]
the mullets need to reach their spawning
grounds further south before
temperatures drop too low
such a massive fish in the sea
doesn't go unnoticed
expert hunters attacked the shoal from
every angle
below are the tarpon and blacktip sharks
above
pelicans
and osprey
as the waves are whipped up by the
approaching storm
the pendulum swings in the mullet's
favor
in the turbulent shallow water
they're harder to target
finally the swells grow too powerful
as the storm makes landfall
along the coast
ocean storms create some of nature's
most awe-inspiring wonders
nazarene in portugal sees some of the
biggest waves in the world
towering as high as 10 stories
[Music]
[Music]
but the stormier our seas become
the more those living on the coast to
suffer
[Music]
an island on the edge of existence
home to rockhopper payments
[Music]
a dense layer of fat gives them some
protection
still
they take a battering
this mother can't back out now
a chick needs food
[Music]
and it's dad's turn to hold the fort
[Music]
life in the colony is tough
declining fish stocks and rougher seas
have made food harder to combine
and what was already a rough sea
is about to get a whole lot rougher
[Music]
the most powerful storm in almost 30
years is closing in
worse than anything these penguins have
faced before
on the far south of the globe
a brutal storm is finally subsiding
but for these rock hopper penguins the
waves are still deadly
[Music]
the latest shift of hunters returns
[Music]
but this chick's mom
is nowhere to be seen
[Music]
then
she appears
amongst the last stragglers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
home and dry
[Music]
so
[Music]
in just 12 hours
she'll return to
once more
right from the very beginning the ocean
has been a cradle of life on our planet
the many creatures that still live here
are really a legacy of that
irrepressible will
to succeed in a turbulent world
no matter what the ocean has thrown at
them
somehow
they've managed to endure
against near impossible odds
this mum-to-be has found her way back
to the beach where she was born
it's the first time she's been on land
since hatching over a decade ago
and she's not alone
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of female olive
ridley turtles
are returning to the costa rican
coastline to lay their eggs
a cycle of life sustained by the sea for
30 million years
never has the journey been harder
yet so far
these turtles are still holding on
in these fast changing times
[Music]
[Music]
you